[Música]
en el cementerio de la localidad rural
de marcelino se celebran entierros de
muertes prematuras
[Música]
esta mañana miro a mi hija y a mis
nietos con mucha tristeza solo dios
puede ayudarme siento mucho dolor y te
vivo estoy en pie desde el sábado solo
dios puede ayudarme dios dame fuerza
para enterrarlos fue que sindica
minerales
la esperanza empieza a desvanecerse los
equipos de búsqueda ya no captan señales
de vida entre las ruinas de los cayos
porque responde a varias lecturas más
del equipo dejó de detectar
fuimos penetrando
hasta que llegamos al piso
esto le digamos a piso y
desafortunadamente no hemos marcado
absolutamente nada
mientras en el campo de fútbol de los
cayos algunos supervivientes perdieron
incluso la fe de poder despedirse de sus
seres queridos mi hermano tenía 28 años
y murió ni siquiera encuentro su cuerpo
para poderlo enterrar más de 2.000
personas murieron entre las ruinas y más
de 100 mil casas quedaron destruidas el
estado de conmoción persiste sin embargo
la llegada de suministros empieza a
cubrir algunas necesidades básicas una
gestión organizada de la ayuda
internacional es el compromiso del
primer ministro ariel en río para
garantizar que las ayudas sean
utilizadas apropiadamente no como en el
terremoto de 2010 cuyas consecuencias
perduran 11 años después
y el hogar me he comprometido a ponerlo
todo en marcha para volver a encarrilar
mi país en una democracia funcional y
organizar lo antes posible elecciones
libres y transparentes
apoyadas por la comunidad internacional
y las autoridades locales las prometidas
elecciones se esperan como un primer
paso de salida de la crisis política
haitiana agravada tras el asesinato del
presidente se ven el mois el 7 de julio